there's no doubt about it Dance Moms is
one of the best reality TV series ever
have you ever wondered where some of
those dancers are now stay tuned to find
out what some of your favorites are
currently up to I can't believe this is
my second choice answer award Joe Josie
Wow
Joe Joe see what might be one of the
most famous dancers from The Dance Moms
franchise she has certainly gone on to
be super successful but first let's take
a look back at her time on the show Joe
Joe first appeared at the Orlando
audition before the fourth season she
replaced Chloe in Abby Lee's elite team
they renamed the team Jojo with the Bobo
it was a reference to all the adorable
bows at Jojo wears
did you know her mom jessalyn makes all
the bows herself they have made Jojo
absolutely iconic Jojo has gone on to be
a pop culture legend she is a talented
musician who has made some amazing music
videos she also has a super-fun youtube
channel we just love how goofy and full
of energy she always is she's even going
on tour in 2019 but that's not all she
is up to she has done some acting and
voicing a character in the new Angry
Birds movie even though she stays crazy
busy she still finds time to do charity
work she recently shared some sweet
photos of her visits to the Omaha
Children's Hospital we love it Jojo is
just an all-around awesome person she's
come so far from her time on Dance Moms
brenn rum follow Brendon first showed up
on Dance Moms in season 5 she was a
member of club dance in Arizona she and
Sarah reasons were guest dancers my name
is
I'm really excited to be here but she
was only there for three episodes she
came back later when she was given free
tuition to the Abby Lee dance company
then she was made a permanent member of
the elite dance team fresh faces
she was super talented and won a bunch
of awards so what has Bren been up to
these days well she took a break from
dancing for a while
she said the show kind of killed her
passion for it we can understand that
Dance Moms is so competitive but we are
happy to report that she is back to
dancing she participated in the move
dance competition in April of 2019 she
also played Charlotte in the two
episodes of the TV show boss chair Brynn
is only 14 years old and she is
definitely staying busy we are really
glad that she is back to dancing because
she's so talented we can't wait to see
what awesome things she does as she gets
older Kalani Hilliker we're throwing it
way back for this next dancer Kalani was
on the second season of Dance Moms
she became Abby's favorite dancer Abby
loved that she was so flexible and had
amazing technique she also just looked
like a dancer Kalani was given free
tuition to Abby's school she was a
member of the elite team for quite a
while eventually though her mom decided
to move them back to Arizona they
decided that family was more important
than Fame the Kalani is still living in
the limelight she just isn't on a
reality TV show anymore Kalani has an
epic YouTube channel she posts vlogs and
orable videos of her family she is
posted makeup tutorials that are totally
on point and she even does collapse with
other stars her channel has over half a
million subscribers she is also a huge
Instagram influencer she's got over 5
million followers she posts about her
life and wraps some awesome merch Kalani
has done some acting lately she has been
playing Sabrina on the TV series dirt
which hits getting better by the second
she is definitely living her best life
we are excited to see what she does in
the next stage of her life kendall vet
kendall ver auditioned way back in the
second season of Dance Moms she was
selected to replace Viviane but Kendall
gave us some serious drama throughout
her time on the show she was put on
probation more than once the second time
it happened her mom took her to a rival
dance company called candy apple
dance center eventually Kendall joined
Abby Lee's elite team
she stayed until season seven when
Ashley and the others decided to form
the irreplaceable Kendall has been
pretty busy since she left two Dance
Moms she has a super active social media
presence she is always with her friends
and family her Instagram bio lists her
as a singer dancer and actress she has
been working on a musical career and she
is in two upcoming films one is called
Anastasia the other is Santa in training
Kendall is still living the dance life
she links to the irreplaceable movie and
her Instagram bio she is also still in
touch with some of her dance sisters
recently she was seen in a car with Jojo
C WA she was wearing a joto bow making
people think she might be in an upcoming
vlog we love that they are still friends
Nia so Frazier we absolutely loved Nia
Frazier Nia was featured on the first
seven seasons of Dance Moms she was one
of the longest-running dancers on the
whole series a lot of fans thought Nia
wasn't always treated fairly by a bee
and aniyah's mom agreed there was lots
of drama between these two Nia is a
super talented dancer she went on to
join Ashley's team the irreplaceable Nia
has been doing amazing things lately she
has a successful Instagram presence and
does quite a bit of modeling
she has also started a music career you
can watch her epic music video down on
YouTube she has such an amazing voice
she goes by Nia sue as a musician she is
also a successful actress she has been
starring on the soap opera the bold and
the beautiful
since 2018 she is amazing on there Nia
is also really smart and is about to
finish high school she has talked about
going to college and studying something
like physical therapy there were some
rumors that she was planning to attend
UCLA she went to an events there and
wore a UCLA shirt but we all know if
that's actually where she is headed we
just know Nia will continue to do
awesome things with her life Chloe Lucas
yak you probably remember Chloe Lucas
yak as Maddie's Ziegler's main
competition Chloe has a big presence in
the first four seasons of Dance Moms she
was one of the top dancers and for good
reason she was considered the number two
dancer on the team Chloe and her mom
left the show after Abby made fun of
Chloe's medical condition Chloe
to dance at studio 19 dance complex she
stopped dancing competitively
but she still takes lessons she made a
guest appearance in season seven of
Dance Moms Chloe is doing amazing things
with her life right now
she has an epic YouTube channel with
almost 2 million subscribers she posts
all sorts of awesome content from makeup
tutorials and DIYs to real life logs she
has done quite a bit of acting she
starred in a movie called loophole in
2017 she has 3 upcoming acting projects
- Chloe is about to graduate from high
school she recently announced that she
will be attending Pepperdine University
in Malibu way to go Chloe it's a great
school we can't wait to see what she
chooses to major in or will she head
into a non Hollywood career whatever she
does we know she'll be great at it
Brooke Hyland Brooke Hyland was the
oldest dancer at the Abby Lee dance
company on Dance Moms
she was really talented but there was a
ton of drama her mom Kelly butted heads
with Abby a lot they even got into a
physical altercation
after that broken her sister had to
leave the Dance Company we didn't get to
see any of her solos on the show because
she competed in an older age group than
most of the girls she has also said that
Dance Moms did not show her true
personality they cut out any times when
she was smiling and laughing Brooke is
now 21 years old and really successful
she has a huge social media following
but most importantly she has just
graduated from college she is obviously
super smart she graduated from the
College of Business at the University of
Ohio and she got not one but two degrees
that's right she double majored in
marketing and management information
systems what's even more impressive is
that she graduated a year early Wow
we love that she is totally winning at
her life who knows what's next for
Brooke Paige Hyland Brookes little
sister Paige was also one of the dancers
on Dance Moms Paige was in the same age
group as most of the other girls but
Abby always considered her one of the
weaker dancers I don't know what's going
on with you
but you need to get your act together
this caused a bunch of drama with Abby
and Paige's mom her mom was not cool
with Paige getting less attention than
the other girls
by season three Abby began to say that
Brooke and Paige were not part of her
studio anymore they apparently just
showed up to record as moms after the
Islands left the show Brooke and Paige
both went on to lead pretty normal lives
Paige is a senior in high school this
year we love seeing all the things she
is up to on her Instagram she recently
went to her senior prom and according to
her social media
she and her date got a flat tire on the
way she said she was grateful he could
change a tire Paige is following in her
big sister's footsteps and is headed to
college she is planning to attend West
Virginia University
according to her Instagram bio she will
graduate in 2023 maybe she'll graduate
early like Brooke dead we are excited to
see what she does after high school
Mackenzie Ziegler Mackenzie was the
youngest star on Dance Moms
she was the younger sister of Maddie
much of her time on the show was spent
being pressured to be like her sister
the two sisters stayed on the show until
season six they worked on other stuff
then joined dance mechanics she is a
talented musician and has released two
albums her most recent one is called
phases and it came out in November of
2018 she is going on tour in the summer
of 2019 with the band pretty much
Mackenzie has also recorded a song for
the ugly dolls movie she has played
Cassie on the TV show total eclipse she
posted music videos blogs and more on
her YouTube channel so she can act
dance and sing what else can she do well
she has a book out called candies rules
for life Wow Mackenzie can really do it
all
we just love that she is building her
musical career it's pretty impressive
that she is only 14 years old her albums
and singles are doing really well and
this summer's tour is a huge opportunity
for her we're excited to see a lot more
from her in the future
Maddie Ziegler the top dancer on Dance
Moms was none other than Maddie Ziegler
she was always Abby's favorite which
caused a bunch of drama with the moms on
the show Maddie is extremely talented
she's also Mackenzie's older sister she
has become a super successful dancer and
actress maddie is currently 16 years old
she has appear as a dancer in six of
Sia's music videos SIA must have really
loved her recently she plays SIA in a
music video from the group LSD she has
done some acting including the movie The
Book of Henry recently Maddie was cast
in the upcoming West Side Story movie
this classical musical with epic dance
numbers is a Steven Spielberg production
Maddie
has really hit it big now nattie
recently hit an impressive 13 million
followers on Instagram wow that is a lot
of fans maddie is still good friends
with some of her other dancers she
attended the 2019 Coachella Festival
with her sister Antonia we can't wait to
see her in her upcoming movie maddie is
definitely a talented superstar and
she's got a long career ahead of her
which Dance Moms dancer is your favorite
let us know in the comments thanks for
watching make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one see
you next time
[Music]